hey I'm Kristian harloff I'm Tiffany
Smith and this is our very special New
Year's episode and we thought we'd give
a little breakdown of all the movies
that we loved we thought were funny
we're surprised by so let's do it this
is oh yeah it might smell waffles all
right technique 2015 is almost over only
a few hours left actually and we have no
guests that's because it's all about our
opinions and no one else opinions matter
what would you give this year's movies
on a scale of 1 to 10 10 being the best
year in the movies 0 ping Wow say about
an 8 I think that the summer season gave
us the popcorn movies that we wanted and
as far as the Oscar muvico I think
that's where we really have been
delivering so I think it's pretty good I
think we got a pretty good mix but first
let's get into maybe the movies that
surprised us the most this year ant-man
for me ant-man was a movie that a lot of
people were saying oh this could be
Marvel's first flub it was really funny
I thought Peyton redid it really a job I
thought it's always nice change of pace
in the hi Billy my role I was pleasantly
surprised by Mad Max I didn't know what
to expect going into it and again one of
my favorite movies of the year there was
no real story line that we went in
knowing and you just went in and the
effects were amazing Tom Hardy was great
charlize theron was amazing and
obviously I want birth mother come back
oh what a day what a lovely day
you
let's get into some of the best comedy
of the year train wrath I laughed more
than I think I've ever laughed in a
movie and didn't expect it I would also
include spy oh my god what working was
less my karthi they really no 1 i'm
jason statham do you know that [ __ ] was
able to do this and that whatever he
says Michael I pjs them not too bad so
how about jason statham gives me another
funny film of the year well you know one
of the things that I really like dope
you don't mind I'll go away from Statham
for a second just talk about dope I
thought it not only didn't have a really
good story and great soundtrack but it
had a lot of laughs and a lot of
outrageous moments that weren't just
outrageous for the safe to be outrageous
it drove the story we get to go see a
lot of movies but sometimes we even get
to be on the red carpets and talk to
some of our favorite actors directors
what were some of your highlights of
this year oh man 1 I got to actually sit
down and talk to Sylvester Stallone for
creed I'm as an eight-year-old kid if
you told me I was gonna do that I would
just fainted our heart attack my brother
had given me that one look at this chest
on top of it was good and speaking of
which I got to talk to Harrison Ford han
Solo himself and he brought up the
Millennium Falcon and parsecs and
everything that I wanted to hear is a
kid I think he wants the ship that
served him well uh the ship that made
the Kessel run 12 parsecs I don't think
there's anything out there to beat it
yeah I got to do the Jurassic world red
carpet premiere uh and that was just so
much fun I learned my photoshop skills
yeah green screen baby hey everyone i'm
here at the jurassic world premiere um
christian this looks ridiculous what are
you gonna do put like a car behind me
and the jurassic world gates no one's
gonna believe this this is lame you have
no idea what people believe let's move
on to my other favorite moment I got to
go to d23 and interview the cast of The
Force awakens hopefully you feel as
badass as I think you are from seeing
that poster thank you I mean I was like
oh my god I'm really in it as well like
my stuff and everything let's get into
just our top movies of the year yeah and
I think to start off for me I think one
of them is absolutely creed I'm a big
rocky fan I was excited to see the movie
because I'm a fan of the franchise but
to watch what
to Ryan Coogler did it bring back
Stallone he's gonna be nominated for an
Oscar and to watch Cindy Fisher this was
a movie that was it far exceeded my
expectations inside out I think just you
know hearing that it's gonna be the
different emotions inside of a kid's
head you're like how is that gonna work
and then you go in and you have all the
fields kids loved it adults loved it it
is a movie is one of the best movies of
the year for sure not just animation now
we can't leave out Star Wars other words
we talked about the force awakens I'll
talk about star wars the force awakens
and it's a movie that we were very
excited how many times have you seen it
now three it is a movie that we've been
waiting essentially 30 years to find out
what happened to Luke Han and Leia and
we find out the question is no longer
who's your favorite han Luke or Leia
who's your favorite han Luke Leia ray
bid Oh Kyle oh there's so many more to
choose from but since it is new years
we've got to talk about the movies we're
looking forward to in 2016 and so I'm
gonna kick this one off to it gotta
start with Batman V Superman dawn of
Justice seeing the trailer that we did
see we got all of it in the trailer all
right we did get a lot in the trailer
that's for sure now Batman V Superman is
going to be competing with civil war and
what will be the best superhero movie of
the year civil war has a good shot I
want to see more of scarlet witch we got
to see characters that had magic powers
in that movie for the first time so
moving forward they're gonna be able to
push that even further which I'm excited
about for me it's always Star Wars
everything Star Wars and for me it's
rogue one why because they got people
that worked on Black Hawk Down Saving
Private Ryan zero dark thirty and
they're making a Star Wars film this is
a war film it takes place right before
episode four and you watch to see how
the glass start oh my god I can't wait
since we are talking about 2016 we like
to make bets here do I think we should
go big and make a pretty epic bet what
do you think is gonna be at the top
grossing film of 2016
okay this is gonna be a tough one
because I think there's a bunch of
contenders out there i'm sure i will
take captain america civil war i think
from the when it comes out in the summer
the fact that it is going / taste
furthering story and you get to see
these guys fight and it is following
Batman V Superman I actually think it's
going to benefit so I'm gonna say civil
work I'm gonna have to go with Batman V
Superman everybody has been waiting to
see Batman and Superman fight you're
gonna get this in this movie and you
know when you look at the numbers from
the last Marvel film with ant-man didn't
do that huge and I feel like we've had
so many of them that this is kind of
starting a new chapter and so I think
the excitement over what is this gonna
be like is gonna top the box office it's
a good bet but it is a terrible choice
well Tiffany we have a full year of
shows here our movie threesome to find
out who's going to be the winner and you
can find me in December 31st 2016 taking
my victory for you guys though make sure
you send in those loser shoulds but
youth ash tag loser should 2016 send
them in all year and make sure they are
at Vic yes like sneaking into the
Playboy Mansion anything that you can
think of that would be cool for me to do
and not harmful do it just want to tell
you all that he said cool for me to do
cuz he thinks he's gonna lose that's all
I gonna say well I just want cool things
when I have to lose either what does he
think you're gonna lose go to commercial
keep digging that hole all right well
you guys thank you all so much for
hanging with us this year in 2015 we'll
see you all again right here in 2016 cuz
there are tons of awesome movies coming
out yeah and get yourself caught up you
do want to watch all of the stuff that
we've done before in 2015 check that out
right there and then subscribe right
over there so you can catch every
that's coming up in 2016 and download
the fandango movie clips app on your
smartphone and then join us every week
on movie